okay so I'm going a little out of order
on this one but at the same time I
couldn't get into into the woods in time
to do a Disney cember for it and yeah
I'll just do it by popular demand in
January but until then let's do what I
actually have gotten a lot of requests
to do The Brave Little Toaster a film a
million times better than its deserving
to be I mean just listen to that title
The Brave Little Toaster this sounds
like a story for one year olds that
should have little to no effort put into
it and even the set up in some respects
is kind of like that to a bunch of
appliances with eyes mouths the whole
thing have been sitting around the house
waiting for their master to return but a
long amount of time has passed and has
turned to feel like he's never going to
come back fearing he might be in trouble
they decide to leave the home and go
looking for him the rest of the film is
the great big journey they take to try
and find where he's gone
our characters include a radio played by
Jon Lovitz a vacuum an electric blanket
a lamp and of course our Brave Little
Toaster for a setup that sounds almost
insultingly simple it's really kind of
surprising how much effort they put into
it there's a lot of quieter moments in
this movie which when I saw as a little
kid I was really impressed by it kind of
made me feel more adult to watch
something that wasn't constantly trying
to be loud and singing and obnoxious it
can let softer moments just be softer
moments oh that's it there's definitely
a lot of craziness in it too they come
across a lot of neat characters a lot of
wonderful designs a lot of scary designs
and even a few hummable musical moments
I especially love the garbage dump song
it has a really good beat to it it even
years later I once in awhile catch
myself humming it
one of the fun things about that you
know I would enjoy is that there's a lot
of scary C's in it yeah for something
called The Brave Little Toaster there's
a lot of really creepy intense moments
look at this climax this is pretty
hardcore for a little kids film
but even beyond that the characters are
actually kind of enjoyable they're all
really simple but really unique and
distinct they all kind of come together
and help each other out as a group and
they all have their moments to shine I
really appreciate this film not just for
being enjoyable but for taking idea that
pretty much had nothing going for it and
just putting their damnedest into it
this is not a lazy project this is
something that people came together said
you know what this is weird this is odd
but we're gonna do everything that we
can with it it's a good film okay not
phenomenal but I don't know what kind of
phenomenal things you can really do with
this set up hell I'm amazed they even
made it - okay standards this is a fun
little adventure to take your kids on it
has enough colorful songs and characters
to keep them interested and enough scary
moments to get them going ooh
what's gonna happen next it's not
spectacular but there's just something
to the atmosphere I really like about it
every action they make you feel the
consequences of and you're totally
rooting for them every step of the way
with a helmet I thought toasters would
lead such interesting lives
Oh